I don't know what's going on
I know
Oh my god
And I understand
Let's do this
Hi! Hey! You made it. Come on in
Oh hi! Wow
You invited them?
This weekend? I mean, have you lost your mind? And you didn't tell me?
Shhhh. I had no choice
Honey, we haven't had sex in a year and a half
We should
talk about the business at hand
Here are the best practices and rules for a swingers party
Dan?
Fun fact
Is it true that you sucked a lot of
Yeah it makes total sense because well, I'm not "exactly" what you were hoping for tonight right?
Do you feel me Dan?
Yeah
My wife, my lovely wife
My husband, my pimp
God, I, I invite you here, you sleep with my goddamn wife
Oh my god
And now you have the nerve to question me?
Will you tell me when you have an erection?
I will let you know
Can you just tell me?
You know, maybe just, we'll just not talk for a little bit
Take my
My wang
Oh my god!
Your glasses are hurting me
Oh okay I'll take them off
Bring it on! Let's do a little Dan and me on you. Like a two on one
A little threeway
Yeah